I'm asking for your help I believe there
is a stranger comes to this village from
the sea it comes in the winter when the
people are hungry it brings fish he
comes on the King tide that was last
night
it won't add felt heed those goodies
kilos of tulips icebergs in the harbor
four months since the last ship got
through well the stranger doesn't come
by ship there are enemies coming from
far away I need warriors I'm building an
alliance and defend ourselves look I'll
give you twenty five thousand to talk to
this man right now outside local TV some
aloud to me over the course it
tell me what those three boxes are and
I'll make it 30 you should get out
can't you at least point me to Atlantis
Arthur curry
also known as protector of the oceans
the Aquaman here you can tuck to fish so
let me get this straight
you do a dress like a bat I get an
actual bat work for twenty years income
so that shit'll fight comes we'll need
you don't count on a Batman why not
don't like you coming here digging into
my business getting into my life goop
from Atlantis tell me do this now you
said you that all of you left alone no
way you help these people out here in
the middle of nowhere because you can
just leave I helped them cuz no one else
does you want to protect them you need
to work with me strong man and strong as
alone never heard that that's not a
saying
that's the opposite of what the saying
is yep doesn't get him wrong
never hear a Superman he died fighting
next to me my point exactly what's in it
three boxes so ancient is true mankind's
melting the polar ice caps destroying
the ecosystem they got it coming
good I don't mind the ocean guys how
about if they boil just like a bat you
out of your mind Bruce Wayne
doesn't mean I'm wrong
you